I want to share a few tips that I have
learned through trying to build my own
morning routine over the last several
years you can absolutely keep it simple
just get up have a shower go to work get
up have a shower make a coffee go to
work get up have a shower go to coffee
maybe do a little bit of meditation
maybe do a little bit of journaling you
can layer these things one by one one at
a time but it's generally a mistake to
try and construct an elaborate one from
scratch it's like building any habit if
you're going to stack habits together
you want to do it slowly you want to do
it one at a time secondly not checking
notifications first thing in the morning
having my phone across from me so that
I'm not tempted to just go and check
notifications immediately it means my
brain is just going to get bombarded
with other people's requests of me and
final tip I wanted to say is this idea
of the daily highlight this thing of
just asking yourself every single
morning what is the most important thing
that I want to do today and I find that
on days when I actually set my daily
highlight I feel like the whole day
comes together a little bit nicer and I
feel like I'm actually spending my time
more intentionally